bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour refaire
la semaine parlementaire avait clamé
côté kathia gilder bonjour et en début
de semaine marquée par la législative
partielle du doubs ce futur dimanche
pour le candidat socialiste frédéric
barbier qui conserve de justesse le
siège de pierre moscovici
la candidate frontiste sophie montel a
remporté près de 49% des suffrages
quelles sont les conséquences de ce
scrutin entre une ump dit viser un ps
soulagé et un fn conforter une semaine
marquée par le marathon législatif sur
la loi matheron beaucoup d'articles un
examen pas de charge et de longues
séances en vue pour espérer aboutir
parmi les dispositions les plus
controversées
l'assouplissement du travail le dimanche
et la réforme des professions
réglementées et pendant que l'assemblée
nationale termine l'examen de la loi
macron le sénat débute celui de la
transition énergétique
un texte porté par la ministre de
l'ecologie ségolène royal mais la
majorité sénatoriale à droite n'entend
pas se laisser faire
bras de fer en vue notamment sur la
question du nucléaire
et pour commenter cette semaine chargée
notre invité s'appelle benoist apparu
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député ump de
la marne ancien ministre chargé du
logement et c'est la coutume de cette
émission je vous propose d'écouter ce
que pensent de vous certains de vos
collègues députés
écoutez nous étions tous les deux
ministre délégué auprès de nathalie
kosciusko morizet lui est ministre
délégué au logement et moi j'étais
délégué ministre délégué aux transports
ça s'est très bien passé voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait dire un bon esprit
c'est fluide
j'ai envie de vous dire sérieux mais il
est livin voilà je veux dire qu'il se
prend pas la tête qui garde les pieds
sur terre
voilà donc à mon avis
un bon élément de très bons éléments
dans la nouvelle génération
benoist apparu est un collègue
sympathique que j'apprécie il a été un
ministre du logement compétents il a
fait ce qu'il a pu dans un contexte
difficile
ce qui me le rend encore plus
sympathique si vous permettez -ce qui
n'est pas très proche c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire de monsieur sarkozy
alors là il me porte à lui faire des
compliments quelqu'un que j'apprécie
qu'à la niaque kaki à 1 franc 1 franc
parler qui a bien géré son ministère du
logement quand il était ministre qui a
le bon goût et et l'intelligence de
continuer à suivre ces dossiers de
logement notamment encore aujourd'hui et
puis qui fait partie je le dis
honnêtement et sincèrement de 2 de ceux
qui compteront qui compte déjà sans
doute aujourd'hui mais qui compteront
après 2017 en tout cas c'est ce que je
sais ce que je lui souhaite un vos
collègues apprécient votre franc-parler
votre agnac finalement benoît paré vous
êtes quelqu'un d'assez consensuelle je
ne sais pas si vous qu'il lit était
auparavant ceo mais j'imagine qu'elle
avait quelques-uns qui était plus
désagréable que ça il y en avait pour
vous rassurer mais globalement c'était
plutôt quand vous vous retrouvez dans ce
portrait oui je me retrouve aussi bien
dans ce portrait ouais on a entendu un
françois loncle un dire qu'il veut qu'il
vous apprécié parce que vous n'étiez pas
très proches de nicolas sarkozy ont fait
plus facilement l'unanimité quand on est
proche d'alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy
à la fin je pense qu'il a tort je me
considère comme proche de nicolas
sarkozy
je me considère comme restant loyal
envers nicolas sarkozy qui a été un très
bon président république il se trouve
que depuis très longtemps et encore
aujourd'hui ma fidélité et pour alain
juppé je considère qu effectivement il
est l'incarnation de ce que nous
pourrions avoir comme de meilleurs comme
prévu la république pour 2010 cette
raison pour laquelle je suis alain juppé
mais ce n'est pas parce que je suis
alain juppé c'est pas parce que je suis
favorable alain juppé que je suis un
ennemi ou un nom proche ou un
je-ne-sais-quoi de nicolas sont peut
être les deux c'est tout ça c'est pas
les deux noms ont fait faire des choix
dans la vie et mon choix il est fait il
est clair il est net
mon choix c'est alain juppé mais c'est
parce que ont choisi alain juppé qu'on
doit forcément prendre un fusil pour
taper sur les autres
benoist apparu on va commencer à
dérouler un cette semaine parlementaire
et on commence bien sûr par le lundi
lendemain de législatives partielles
dans le doubs et s'est passé ric-rac
pour frédéric barbier dimanche dans le
doubs face à la candidate frontiste
sophie montel le socialiste conserve de
justesse le siège de pierre moscovici
dont il était le suppléant
alors quelle conséquence les parties
tires tu de ce scrutin on voit ça avec
mari la bat 863 c'est le nombre de voix
d'avancé qu'il aura fallu au candidat ps
frédéric barbier pour remporter
l'élection législative partielle dans le
doubs hier avec 51,43 % des suffrages
exprimés
sa victoire face à la candidate fn
sophie montel il la veut donc modeste si
bien sûr ce soir je précise ce succès
succès collectif
je me réjouis mort jeune bâloise pas ce
fut difficile très difficile
ce succès je le dois ce rassemblement
est large des forces républicaines et de
votre action imputée à tous car au front
national
ce second tour est clairement vu comme
une victoire nous sommes là ce soir face
à une recomposition de la vie politique
française en ce sens que le tripartisme
a volé en éclat que le front national ce
soir est le premier parti de france
seul le front national arrive à 49,1 %
ce soir contre une caste est un système
voilà qui se monterait à l'évidence
incapable de gagner seul consensus à
droite comme à gauche les politiques
tirent donc la sonnette d'alarmé
je reste très lucide sur l'état de la
france sur la crise de confiance que
connaît notre pays et sur le danger que
représente le front national surtout
quand en face la digue la digue n'est
pas suffisamment solide pour obtenir une
formation politique qui ne pousse pas
les valeurs de la république de
l'élection doit servir d'électrochoc
nous devons combattre avec beaucoup plus
de force le front national que nous
l'avons fait jusqu'à présent
cette victoire permet au ps de mettre
fin à une série noire de 12 défaites à
delhi
ce natif partiel depuis 2012 et surtout
de regagner la majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale benoist apparu
la position choisie par l'ump pour cette
législative est elle responsable
c'est une question franche et directe
est ce qu'elles étaient responsables en
tout cas c'était la sienne il ne vous
aura pas échappé que j'étais pas tout à
fait sur cette ligne là et que j'avais
comme d'autres annoncé qu à titre
personnel j'aurais voté pour le candidat
non front national à savoir celui du
parti socialiste l'ump après une
position cette position elle n'est pas
nouvelle
la position du ni-ni elle a 10 ans 15
ans et on continue à avoir des débats
autour cette position pourquoi parce
qu'on l'évoqué thaler dans votre
première question le rôle d'un homme
politique fait choisir cette franche et
cdh arbitres essaient de prendre des
décisions c'est pas de rester entre
guillemets sur une ligne ambivalente
il me semble effectivement nous devront
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent faire des choix plus fort que
ce que nous avons fait moi la position
de nicolas sarkozy celle qu'il avait
présentée au vote du bureau politique à
savoir pas de vote front national et
pour le reste peut être que vous et
c'est à dire ps blanc ou abstention est
une position que je suis prêt à signer
et qui pour être me semble-t-il une
position de compromis entre les uns et
les autres
est ce que vous demandez une réunion du
bureau politique de l'ump pour changer
de ligne d'ici les départementales ne
pas faire un bureau politique toutes les
semaines pour aborder toutes les
semaines la question est tranchée
j'imagine que la question se reposera
après les départementales avant n'est
pas entre le bureau politique a pris une
décision il ya quinze jours pour vous
faire plaisir
il ya plein de caméras au bureau
politique on peut refaire une semaine
toutes les semaines une réunion du
bureau politique pour poser la même
question
toutes les semaines mais a priori à une
décision qui a été prise
donc on verra effectivement en fonction
de l'actualité départementale s'il ya
lieu ou pas de remettre ça c'est presque
demain les deux fortement talent oui
parce que dans un mois et demi quand
même c'est pas le nom mais ça ça passe
vite qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
proposition de nathalie koscuisko
morizet de consulter de faire voter les
militants pour définir la ligne
adoptée notamment face au fn est ce que
c'est une piste à suivre ou un piège à
éviter
la solution peut être envisagée pense
qu'on connaît à peu près la réponse à la
question qui sera qui sera posée moi il
me semble que là encore c'est aux
dirigeants politiques de guider des
choix et c'est aux dirigeants politiques
souhaitent été investi par les militants
pour le faire d'assumer ses prises de
position politiques
et vous pensez que les militants
écoutent encore les consignes de vote
j'ai beaucoup de problèmes avec cette
formule qui consiste à dire il ne faut
pas donner de consigne de vote
pourquoi le rôle de chacun dans une
campagne électorale c'est quoi c'est ça
c'est le principe même d'une campagne
électorale c'est de dire aux électeurs
voter pour untel
quand je fais campagne pour un candidat
pour alain juppé par exemple mais je
vais dire aux électeurs consigne de vote
je vous demande de voter alain juppé est
donc un politique commence à dire ouh là
les consignes de vote c'est pas génial
ça me pose question
ça veut dire qu'on a écouté pour autant
baisser son rideau de fer alors cette
semaine vous avez beaucoup siéger ce
n'est pas fini il ya de longues séances
en perspective l'assemblée joue les
prolongations avec la loi macron
beaucoup de raffut dans l'hémicycle
notamment sur le travail le dimanche
mais aussi sur la question des
privatisations qui était à l'ordre du
jour concernées notamment les aéroports
de nice et de lyon explications de
séance avec rim benameur vif débat
autour de la privatisation dans
l'hémicycle les députés ont adopté des
articles très divers ouverture du
capital du lfb un laboratoire qui
produit des médicaments dérivés du sang
à des organismes publics comme la bpi
privatisation de next heures un
constructeur de blindés français pour
permettre son rapprochement avec son
homologue allemand mais c'est l'article
49 sur la privatisation des aéroports de
nice et de lyon qui a fait le plus débat
vous nous proposer la mise en vente de
deux des trois plus grands aéroports que
compte notre pays aujourd'hui dans le
but de rendre une copie propre à
bruxelles
mais cette démarche permettez moi de
vous le dire monsieur le ministre
ce n'est pas digne d'un homme d'état je
dirais que davantage c'est une démarche
d'un bain qui est préoccupé par la seule
réalisation d'une plus-value
il n'y a aucune légitimité à ce que vous
mettiez en vente un actionnaire
majoritaire qui demain n'aura qu'un
intérêt c'est certes de faire monter les
dividendes à un niveau plus élevé mais
pas celui de contribuer au développement
économique territorial
autre sujet omniprésent dans l'hémicycle
la méthode mâcon monsieur le ministre
avec cet article vous exprimer une forme
d'impatience
un dénommé vladimir ilitch oulianov
d'ailleurs parlé de d'impatience petite
bourgeoise à moins que ce soit
l'expression d'une boulimie ou petit à
petit article après article vous
attribuer les domaines de compétences
des différents ministres je commence à
devenir un vrai mac rognant parce que il
ya une certaine fraîcheur dans votre
vérité monsieur le ministre
quand vous dites est ici bien vous avez
dit on a essayé de me tuer pendant ce
débat ensuite je me suis trompé
après dix jours de discussions les
parlementaires sont à peine arrivé à un
quart des 200 articles de la loi macron
ils vont donc siégé tout le week end
benoist apparu vous allez laisser penser
que vous pourriez voter ce texte vous
avez vous ne voterez ipa aujourd'hui
puisque vous le voter ce texte flou je
vais le voter
est ce que je devrais faire boutons mais
je lèverai non non vous allez voter jean
spa en revirements j'étais très hésitant
parce que pourquoi des bonnes choses et
des choses moins bonnes la privatisation
des aéroports
je pas le point de vue de christian
estrosi parce que je suis moins concert
avec lui mais ça me paraît plutôt une
bonne chose
par contre j'étais beaucoup plus réservé
beaucoup plus opposés à ce qui se
dessinait sur les professions
réglementées ou plutôt favorable à ce
qui se passe sur le dimanche
plus réservé sur dexter bref une
position assez ambivalente parce que du
bon et du beaucoup moins bon
malheureusement pendant ces débats
parlementaires on est passé de 100
à 200 articles petit bagatelle on va
avoir une loi épaisse comme ça on va
avoir des décrets épais comme ça et on
va nous dire qu'il nous faut faire un
choc de simplification ça peut pas
marcher
donc il ya un moment il faut qu'on
arrête cette boulimie législative
il faut qu'on arrête en cours de débat
devra douter des choses aussi
insignifiante canal c'est que le canal
seine nord
la baguette et le 5 milliards d'euros en
europe ça arrive par amendement
gouvernemental comme ça parce que on
avait dû oublier ses revenus donc hop
dans le fourre tout macron on met cet
élément aussi bon pour toutes ces
raisons là je trouve que j'étais très
partagés vu la tonalité des débats très
peu d'amendements de l'opposition repris
par le gouvernement sans une centaine
d'articles de plus évidemment en
provenance tous de la majorité je trouve
que ce n'est pas très sérieux et donc je
voterai donc les députés siègeront ce
week-end est ce que comme vigeo
christian jacob vous dénoncez une
surcharge de travail parlementaire on
est là pour siéger donc que non je ne
dénonce pas de surcharge mauvaise
organisation du pas très belles choses
vous disiez quitter lens entre les deux
et les bains effectivement je trouve que
non là encore et si on est d'avoir un
minimum minimum d'honnêteté
intellectuelle
il me semble que ceux qui ont inventé le
régime actuel du fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
c'est nous quand nous étions au
gouvernement donc maintenant quelques
années après à dire finalement c'est pas
si bien que ça bon voilà essayons d'être
cohérent le gouvernement veut aller vite
on peut les comprendre on a je crois le
temps de débattre
on peut éviter aussi de répéter 18 fois
la même chose les uns et les autres et
donc on a le jeu croit le temps de
débattre finalement examinée le travail
du dimanche un dimanche le gouvernement
ça peut être une chance pour moi c'est
cohérent une petite question sur les la
privatisation des aéroports y aura jeudi
une votation à nice vous en pensez quoi
est-ce que c'est risqué d'ouvrir le
secteur stratégique
vous non s'est pas risqué ça ne me pose
pas de problème que quelques grands
aéroports français soit soit privé me
semble tout dans une ou des fonds dont
plutôt un principe d'économie de marché
plutôt le libéralisme que le socialisme
et libéralisme c'est me semble-t-il
plutôt le privé que le public peut être
aussi qu'on peut s'accorder sur le fait
que la sphère publique française est
quand même juste gigantesque qu'à partir
du moment où on veut effectivement se
dire qu'il faut se reconcentrer sur les
fonctions régaliennes de l'état la
justice la sécurité intérieure et
extérieure
évidemment la laïcité bref sur quelques
grands principes quelques grands
domaines de compétences qui sont le
coeur de fonctionnement de l'état
peut-être qu'on peut se dire
effectivement que être propriétaire
d'aéroports de province n'est peut-être
pas peut-être pas indispensable alors
mardi le sénat a débuté l'examen du
projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique un texte défendu par
ségolène royal
un texte que la majorité sénatoriale de
droite comptent bien modifié pour
imposer ses vues notamment sur le
nucléaire
quels sont les principaux points de ce
texte les explications de faustine saint
joseph c'est un nouveau bras de fer qui
s'annonce entre le sénat et le
gouvernement lors de l'examen du projet
de loi sur la transition énergétique
premier point de friction et non des
moindres le nucléaire françois hollande
l'a promis il veut ramener la part du
nucléaire de 75 à 50% dans le mix
électrique français en 2025 une promesse
d'ores et déjà amputée en commission au
sénat les sénateurs de la majorité sont
d'accord pour limiter la part du
nucléaire mais sans fixer
date ils jugent objectif peu réaliste et
surtout coûteux ne cassons pas justement
la machine ne jetons pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain
on voit bien ce que ça donne en
allemagne aujourd'hui on a une contre
exemple contre exemple c'est que les
allemands brutalement de manière ils
sont en brut albon veulent sortir du
nucléaire
vous avez vu le résultat des courses
autre point de discorde
l'isolation des bâtiments le texte du
gouvernement prévoyait une isolation par
l'extérieur
les sénateurs eux veulent assouplir
cette mesure est laissée rohmer la
liberté de décider de la technique
choisie par ailleurs les sénateurs ont
voulu insister sur un aspect qu'il juge
oublié dans le texte la biomasse avec
les biocarburants ou encore le chauffage
au bois
objectif favoriser son développement sur
tout le territoire
autres thèmes plus consensuel cette fois
la circulation automobile
le texte vise à développer des
transports propres notamment électriques
et hybrides ou encore à restreindre la
circulation en cas de mauvaise qualité
de l'air bonnet a paru cette semaine en
séance le sénat a maintenu l'objectif de
réduction à 50% de la part du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité mais en
supprimant l'échéance de 2025
est-ce que selon vous c'est une bonne
chose est ce que cette promesse de
campagne de françois hollande et est
irréaliste totalement irréaliste on
l'avait dénoncée en son temps passé en
l'espace de dix ans de 75% notre
production énergétique électrique pardon
du nucléaire vers le à 50% pardon sur
dix ans est totalement irréaliste
non seulement irréaliste mais
écologiquement parlant dangereux parce
que les substitutions sénateurs
l'évoquait l'instant on le voit en
allemagne on est repassé au charbon je
suis pas sûr que ce soit un progrès
absolument délirant pour l'environnement
et la planète donc que l'on baisse la
part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique français pourquoi pas c'est
un débat qu'on peut avoir qui est
légitime simplement faisons le sur un
rythme acceptable et non pas du jour au
lendemain parce que dix ans en matière
nucléaire c'est excessivement court non
pas du jour au lendemain parce que là
c'est dangereux pour l'indépendance
énergétique
dangereux pour l'environnement et c'est
dangereux pour la facture des français
il pourra lâcher des français il ya
beaucoup de mesures dans ce texte c'est
aussi donc ces mesures sur l'isolation
des logements est ce que pour vous tous
assez facile vous avez été ministre du
logement
facile à mettre en oeuvre ou au
contraire c'est les douze travaux
d'hercule non ça me paraît intéressant
effectivement de travailler sur les
questions d'isolation des bâtiments
la seule question que je me pose est ce
que c'est vraiment à la loi de dire
qu'il faut isoler comme ça alors ça et
quand c'est ça ma question qui se tourne
a relaté une absurdité de ces textes qui
n'en finissent plus besoin d'une
absurdité complet est ce qu'on peut de
temps en temps en france faire confiance
aux gens dont c'est le métier et se dire
que nous notre métier c'est de fixer des
objectifs éventuellement de les
quantifier
éventuellement on peut avoir des débats
de les dater et de dire voilà nous
considérons que demain une maison doit
dépensé tant d'énergie et fixer les
règles des raisons générales et les
c'est effectivement derrière aux
professionnels le soin de le faire
là encore l'isolation des bâtiments à la
montagne dans le doubs à châlons en
champagne à marseille ou à la réunion
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
arrêtons donc de faire des règles qui
lorsqu'elles sont inadaptées nécessite
de faire une nouvelle loi
résultat sur le logement en vingt ans on
a fait un droit très rapidement devenir
le mans france de trop très rapidement
sur ce sujet françois hollande parle
beaucoup d'écologie ces derniers temps
est ce que ce nouvel amour du président
pour l'écologie selon vous il est
sincère ou électoralistes pour
reconquérir les verts je sens que dans
votre question il ya plus d'arrières
pensées je le sens essaimant je crois
que je partage vos arrières pensées et
j'ai cru comprendre qu'effectivement
pour françois hollande comme il sait
maintenant que 1000 et assuré qu'il n'y
aura pas de primaires au sein du parti
socialiste
son but j'imaginais de recoller les
morceaux d'une majorité pour le moins
brisé entre les communistes et le front
de gauche d'un côté les verts de l'autre
le ps lui-même divisé
je pense qu'il va essayer de retisser un
peu les liens de tout ça est un petit
retour des verts au gouvernement à mon
avis lui ferait largement plaisir raison
pour laquelle je crois il redécouvre
l'écologie c'est dommage qu'il la
redécouvre exclusivement pour des
questions électorales
alors on avance on passe à mercredi où
on parle de la réserve parlementaire
la réserve c'est cette enveloppe
réservée aux députés et aux sénateurs
pour des projets exceptionnels de leur
circonscription que les communes ne
peuvent pas financer seuls des règles
ont été adoptées pour plus de
transparence
où en est on voyez ce sujet de paul
bouffard c'est en effet une enveloppe de
crédits qui est ed steen et à aider des
collectivités locales ça permet
d'épauler des projets et dans le
règlement la réserve parlementaire est
distribué en cas de circonstances
exceptionnelles des projets que les
collectivités ne peuvent assumer seule
la cour des comptes le dit l'esprit
d'origine et détourner l'enveloppent
serait devenu un mode de financement
régulier restaurer un clocher ou encore
construire une route suppression réforme
au sénat les coeurs balancent
mais tous sont d'accord en période de
baisse des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités
ça peut aider si on la supprime fully
moins de travail mais aussi encore un
peu d'argent en moins nous dans le val
de marne ya 47 communes cantons à 130000
euros pour 47 communes vous voyez que ça
fait pas grand chose donc quand on donne
5000 ou 10000 euros à une commune
on participe même pas 3 % ou 1 5% lui
réparation des traits d'une école
l'aménagement d'une bibliothèque autres
et elle n'est fait peu pour les dépenses
d'investissement et pas du tout pour le
fonctionnement autre constat alarmant la
flambée de cette réserve en période
électorale
les sages brocard cette pratique en 2006
veille de législatives et
présidentielles l'enveloppent aurait
gonflé de 113 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sans justification on
n'a jamais eu un parlementaire se faire
réélire parce qu'il avait distribué de
l'ariège parlementaire vous dire que les
députés veulent distribuer aux dingues
qui veulent canadien ou deux
allez zou et notre coup de vent
ils sont mariés le gros temps pour
gérard miquel la réserve par nos
parlementaires d'exister sur le terrain
de maintenir un lien avec les
collectivités
chaque année l'enveloppent s'élève à 150
millions d'euros répartis entre députés
et sénateurs
ce qu'il faut maintenir cette réserve
parlementaire à l'heure où les dotations
aux collectivités locales baisse ou est
ce qu'il faudrait supprimer
moi je suis plutôt favorable au maintien
de la réserve parlementaire
peut-être pour des raisons similaires à
celles que tu es qui ont été évoqués
peut-être pour d'autres
je ne crois pas à la théorie du
subventionnement exceptionnel je crois
simplement que le député ou sénateur est
un objet politique un peu haddock dans
un terrain sur un terrain comme on dit
sur le terrain dans la marne wire vous
avez un maire qui a un budget et qui
peut investir dans son territoire
vous avez un conseiller général qui via
le conseil général peut en faire de même
le député est un élu qui n'a pas le
budget en tant que tel parce qu'il ne
gère pas une collectivité locale avoir
un microbudget dès lors qu'il est
transparent pour permettre effectivement
de délivrer un certain nombre de
subventions à des collectivités locales
ou à quelques associations paraît plutôt
plutôt une bonne chose
j'y mets évidemment des conditions comme
tout le monde la transparence totale et
que les règles actuelles de transmission
des subventions aux questions restent
les mêmes parce que je rappelle que
c'est pas une enveloppe que récupère le
député et qu'il distribue
c'est en fait un droit de tirage sur les
subventions ministérielles
autrement dit je vais dire au ministère
de l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
merci de bien vouloir donner à la
commune de sainte-menehould link rel
subventions et c'est le ministère qui
envoie l'argent à la préfecture à la
préfecture pardon qu'il est blanc voit à
la commune en question donc arrêtons là
encore c'est le sport français d'en
faire un fantasme absolu de l'envelope
bien caché que le mythe du député ou
sénateur va distribuer comme ça en
dessous de table c'est pas du tout la
réalité est ce que cependant il faudrait
pas indexé cette réserve parlementaire
sur le taux de présence des
parlementaires
c'est une piste envisagée on peut
trouver effectivement des idées
intéressantes de ce point de vue là
assez d'accord sur le fait que voilà il
ya des travail qui est différent entre
les uns et les autres moi ça ne poserait
pas de question effectivement qu'on ait
ce type de show de la reine la cour des
comptes avait alerté sur la réserve pas
loin
est ce que c'est un lanceur dallaire de
la république la cour des comptes tire
sur est évidemment vous les reconnaissez
ce que je lui connais le reconnaît non
seulement ce rôle mais je considère
qu'il nous faudrait 15 cour des comptes
sur les thématiques différentes
je m'explique la france est un pays qui
est le champion de l'annonce le champion
de la loi et une fois qu'on a annoncé
une réforme fait la loi on considère que
le boulot est fait si la france se poser
plus de questions sur la mise en oeuvre
de la loi et surtout sur l'évaluation
des politiques publiques pour voir si ça
a marché
pas marché ce qu'il faut changer on
serait je crois beaucoup plus efficace
et il nous faudrait 15 cour des comptes
pour qu'on puisse avoir beaucoup plus
régulièrement qu'aujourd'hui des
évaluations de nos politiques publiques
pour savoir si ça marche si ça marche
pas si c'est coûteux pas coûteux au
moins avec la cour des comptes
nous avons une institution reconnue
comme objectif qui nous dit ce qui est a
priori pas mal a priori pas bien et non
suspect de polliniser les débats c'est
exceptionnellement bien mercredi alain
juppé était devant l'association des
journalistes parlementaires le maire de
bordeaux est resté droit dans ses bottes
notamment sur la question des alliances
avec le centre on écoute le grand échec
de l'ump c'est 2012
quand les centristes nous quitte oui je
regrette que lui dit nous ait quittés
parce qu'elle était parmi donc elle est
partie et puis moi je vais un coup plus
loin
si le modem est clair dans sa volonté
d'alternance
s'il n'est pas le cul entre deux chaises
et bien il a toute sa place parmi nous
et je vais au delà il ya aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de sociaux-démocrates au
parti socialiste qui n'apprécie pas la
façon dont ce parti conduit la france et
qui est prêt à envisager autre chose
donc soyons ouverts je pense que c'est
le bon sens jean christophe lagarde à
dix elle se met à cette semaine qu'il
souhaitait un candidat centriste à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 il
fait une erreur le président du pays je
suis pas juge et des positions du
goudron du lit savoir s'il fait une
erreur ou pas quelque chose qui est un
candidat centriste et un candidat de
l'ump
moi ce qui me paraît très souhaitable
c'est qu'on arrive les uns et les autres
à se mettre d'accord sur une procédure
les primaires pour des
nier le champion entre guillemets de la
droite et du centre pour que nous
n'arrivions pas divisée au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle parce que
le risque et les sondages nous le montre
c'est que du coup on se retrouve dans la
configuration du nous c'est à dire
numéro un le fromage numéro 2 le ps
on peut peut-être essayé de l'éviter et
pour l'éviter il me semble que se mettre
d'accord sur une candidature unique au
premier tour d'élection présidentielle
est donc un choix préalable par les
électeurs de la droite et du centre via
une primaire ouverte me paraîtrait plus
tôt un gage de sagesse ou prendre un
prochain aussi d'alain juppé et de
françois bayrou parce que ça vous porte
vous ça vous paraît opportun j'ai un
vrai problème d' analyse par rapport à
ça parce qu'on nous dit souvent que
françois bayrou nous a fait perdre en
c'est probablement pas tout à fait faux
et donc si je comprends bien on veut
recommencer la même chose en 2010 est
donc c'est une mauvaise idée non c'est
la verse
si françois bayrou nous a fait perdre en
2017 parce qu'il a voté ps et qu'on fait
tout pour qu'ils votent aussi ps en 2010
un système mais peut-être qu'on aura le
même résultat en 2010 est qu'en 2012 ce
que je veux éviter donc oui à partir du
moment où françois bayroux a affirmé à
plusieurs reprises qu'il était qu'il
considérait qu'il avait peut-être pas
fait la meilleure des choses qui soient
en 2012
à partir du moment où françois bayrou et
le modem parce qu'il n'est pas tout seul
est droit dans ses bottes
c'est à dire qu'il nous dit oui je suis
dans l'opposition à la politique menée
actuellement oui ayons des primaires y
compris avec le modem
faisons une majorité avec l'ensemble des
centres pour se dire on a perdu parce
que les centristes n'étaient pas tous
avec toi en 2012 eh bien faisons pas la
même bêtise une seconde fois
on va continuer par les uns d'alain
juppé on accueille à présent notre
partenaire du figaro pour un décryptage
de l'actuelle la langue du scan
benoist apparu bonjour bonjour
justement on évoquait les questions
d'alliances avec le centre alain juppé a
été sifflé plusieurs fois à ce sujet je
crois qu'on peut voir une petite
séquence qui datent de samedi dernier au
conseil national de l'ump
c'est quelque chose qui a tendance à
assumer
il a mercredi devant la presse
parlementaire il est dit qu'il s'y
attendait il a même un peu ironisé en
disant qu'ils s'étaient rendus qu'un
gilet pare-balles un casque à boulons
à quoi joue alain juppé s qui joue la
provocation vis-à-vis des sarkozystes et
d'une base qui est pro sarkozy elle même
c'est pas de la provocation
quand on est dans un parti politique
devant ses amis politiques devant les
adhérents l'ump
il faut assumer ses positions si la
salle n'est pas d'accord c'est dommage
mais c'est pas grave
assumer quelques différences par rapport
à ça et donc pour moi le rôle d'alain
juppé comme de nicolas sarkozy comme
tout le monde d'ailleurs c'est pas de
céder à une salle et de dire à la salle
ce qu'elle veut entendre le rôle d'un
homme politique est plutôt d'ailleurs
d'un homme d'état n'est pas de suivre
l'opinion c'est d'essayer de la guider
qu'est ce qui différencie d'ailleurs un
homme politique d'un homme d'état et
donc oui moi je considère qu alain juppé
doit rester sur ça l'est il n'est
évidemment pas majoritaires sur cette
ligne là au sein des militants de l'ump
c'est possible mais c'est pas une raison
suffisante en soi pour changer de point
de vue est-ce qui est pas un risque
justement pour la primaire de 2016 il va
bien falloir faire campagne
est ce qu'il va faire campagne sans les
militants mais une campagne électorale
c'est prendre des risques c'est assumer
des positions et là encore des positions
fortes franche qui sont ceux que l'on a
au plus profond de ses tripes pour
essayer d'amener les gens à suivre une
position dans les sérails convaincre les
militants à 1 que la position qui est la
nôtre est plutôt gage de victoire en
2017 mais au delà du gage de la victoire
en 2017
surtout que nos positions soit le bon
angle le bon axe économique et social
pour derrière goût
un pays parce qu'il faut surtout se
mettre une chose dans la tête
si on veut faire durablement bc
l'antiparlementarisme lentilles
politique
l'anti si on veut éviter de faire monter
le front national c'est que notre métier
principal notre fonction principale
c'est pas la conquête électorale
c'est l'exercice des responsabilités du
pouvoir
or les français considèrent au considère
aujourd'hui que la seule chose qui nous
intéresse c'est de gagner les élections
et bien non ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de gouverner un pays beaucoup plus que
de gagner alors autre chose qui nous a
interpellés cette semaine
ozcan justement pour gagner des
élections va falloir reconstruire une
machine politique à l'ump c'est un des
projets nicolas sarkozy est un
questionnaire qui a été envoyé à tous
les adhérents
je voudrais vous avoir votre avis sur
trois points assez rapidement dans ce
questionnaire était demandé si le
principe des primaires ouvertes doit
être posée pour les élections locales et
des investitures aux législatives qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
je suis partagé je suis partagé parce
que j'ai participé à la rédaction de ce
questionnaire et j'ai approuvé les quais
les questions il est légitime qu'on
interroge les les militants là dessus je
suis partagé parce que d'un côté je ne
peux pas dire il faut une primaire pour
2017 et dire c'est que pour la
présidentielle
dès que ça me concerne moi pour mon cd
député je suis pas favorable en même
temps sur le principe des primaires par
exemple on va probablement acheter le
fait les primaires nationales j'entends
que lorsqu'il ya un président de la
république sortant
il n'y a pas de primaires pour les
législatives où les municipales même
question qu'est ce qui se passe quand on
a un sortant qu'est ce qui se passe
quand ya pas de sortant donc que l'on
dise quand il n'ya pas de membres de la
formation politique ump évidemment qu'on
organise des primaires pour les
élections locales peut-être pourquoi pas
ça peut être une bonne méthode de choix
quand il y à un sortant
je suis plutôt en défaveur et donc de ce
point de vue là si on applique la même
règle que pour la présidentielle
pourquoi pas alors merci marc de boni
pour cette l'open nice cannes et on va
avancer au jeudi
on vous parle un peu de l'international
avec ce plan de paix arraché au forceps
pour l'ukraine françois hollande est un
gala merkel ont réussi à convaincre
vladimir poutine de signer un texte avec
son homologue ukrainien petro porochenko
un accord pour un cessez le feu et pour
le retrait de toutes les armes lourdes
des deux côtés c'est un accord pour
l'instant sur le papier on ne sait pas
si ce sera respectée ou pas benoist
apparu
est ce que pour vous c'est une victoire
de la diplomatie européenne ou au
contraire une victoire de vladimir
poutine
sans le dire a manqué l'avenir le dira
dans quelques semaines et
malheureusement je le crains dans
quelques années
en tout cas la diplomatie européenne a
été présente
elle a assumé une position elle a pris
des risques et c'est plutôt sain ça
montre que l'europe politique ça peut
exister ça peut compter et ça peut
peut-être même avoir des résultats donc
une bonne chose
de ce point de vue là maintenant tous
les observateurs le disent ce
cessez-le-feu est fragile comme
malheureusement le précédent qui avait
été signé également un mixte a été
fragile et n'a pas tenu
espérons évidemment que je suis la
tienne mais c'est pas parce que il est
fragile qu'il ne fallait pas aller
jusqu'au bout des négociations aller
jusqu'au bout du deal pour éviter un
engrenage et françois hollande dans tout
ça est un bon négociateur il négocie
même des contrats sur le rafale avec
l'egypte bon négociateur salon mais
heureusement qu'il n'est pas que mauvais
heureusement qu'il ya des points sur
lesquels il fait bien son job il a bien
fait son job au mois de janvier là
effectivement il est dans son rôle comme
il en or son rôle et il ne fait bien de
réussir à vendre le rafale
s'ils pouvaient essayer d'appliquer un
peu les mêmes méthodes pour les grandes
questions économiques et sociales et
être bon aussi là dessus je pense que
les français l'apprécierez d'autant plus
jeudi c'est jour de questions
d'actualité au sénat et à cette occasion
dans l'hémicycle le premier ministre
manuel valls assez longuement exprimé
sur la question de l'islam on écoute le
défi considérable de faire la
démonstration que dans notre pays ou en
europe
oui l'islam est fondamentalement
incompatible avec les valeurs de la
république
que je viens de rappeler ce qui veut
dire qu'il faudra poser toutes les
questions comment accepter par exemple
que l'islam de france reçoivent des
financements d'un certain nombre de pays
étrangers
quel qu'il soit c'est une première
question qui doit être posée et si on la
pose et bien ça veut dire qu'il faut
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
pour demain empêcher ces financements
notamment quand il le conforte un
certain nombre de comportements
il faut donc mettre tous les sujets sur
la table celui du financement des lieux
de culte et des activités liées au culte
celui des dérives radical celui de la
sécurité de la sérénité au fait qu'elle
les musulmans de france ont droit comme
tous les citoyens
benoist apparu manuel valls a raison de
mettre ce débat sur la table
oui il a raison on peut pas continuer à
occulter ce débat là il ya de le
ressortir que de temps en temps il
faudra aller au bout de la démarche
c'est le bon moment si jamais le bon
moment
on peut toujours trouver une autre
occasion il se trouve que il y à un
débat depuis le mois de janvier sur la
place de l'islam de france et en france
qu'il faudra bien arbitré un moment ou
un autre
je partage cette analyse qui vient
d'être développée par le premier
ministre qui consiste à dire quoi 1
nous devons assumer la construction d'un
islam de france
ça veut dire une hiérarchie du clergé
musulman pour que les autorités
françaises est un interlocuteur comme
elles l'ont pour les deux grandes autres
religions monothéistes 7 me semble-t-il
un angle essentiel deuxième angle il
nous faut des humains qu'ils soient
formés en france il y a un diplôme
universitaire aline rc strasbourg qui
permettrait par exemple de valider le
processus de formation des imams en
question pour qu'on soit sur un qui
parle français d'être complètement
insignifiant
et deux qu'il respecte bien évidemment
les valeurs de la république qui est un
cadre universitaire de formation des
imams pour qu'ils puissent exercer en
france me paraît une bonne chose
3 il ya effectivement des règles de
financement a sécurisé pour que l'on
évite que telle mosquée soit financée à
70 % par des fonds en provenance du
maroc de l'algérie d'arabie saoudite où
turquie et que l'on est
figement un contrôle de ces financements
là et donc sur ces trois points par
exemple je crois que nous devons avait
ces avancées pardon arrêter d'en parler
et le faire je vous parle de swiss
l'iksv le nom des révélations dans la
presse d'un vaste ce système d'évasion
fiscale mis en place par la filiale
suisse de hsbc
c'est notre plus de l'hebdo un mécanisme
complexe organisé de fuite de capitaux
tels sont les révélations de plusieurs
journaux dont le monde selon ces sources
la banque hsbc or est aidé certains de
ses riches clients à cacher des
milliards de dollars pour échapper à
l'impôt le scandale ce chris leak c'est
un sujet de simon barbarie cent mille
contribuables transformer en évadés
fiscaux tous clients de la banque
britannique hsbc 2 novembre 2006 à mars
2007 des sommes auraient transité par
les comptes de clients et de sociétés
offshore swiss l'x un nouveau scandale
selon le journal le monde plus de 11
milliards d'euros d'actifs français
auraient été dissimulées au sénat en
une commission d enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale chiffrer la perte de 30 à 60
milliards d'euros pour les caisses de
l'état des français sont en bonne place
dans le scandale banque idéal pour gad
elmaleh l'humoriste aurait bénéficié
d'un contour opposé 80000 euros
jacques dessange l'empereur de la
coiffure en france 1,6 million d'euros
ou encore des sportifs
le footballeur christophe dugarry aurait
soustrait 2 millions d'euros au fisc
français
depuis 2007 des outils rend difficile la
fraude le secret bancaire se restreint
avec notamment les échanges de
renseignements il deviendra automatique
en 2018
bercy permet dès aujourd'hui aux
détenteurs de comptes non déclarés de
régulariser leur situation
habituellement de 40% la pénalité est
réduite à 20 %
dans un communiqué hsbc affirme avoir
changé après les manquements constatés
en 2007
la banque aurait fait le ménage dans son
portefeuille clients un commentaire de
paul bouffard benoist apparu des
affaires des scandales là depuis des
années il ya eu aussi beaucoup d' alerte
une prise de conscience et une action
mondiale pour lutter contre ces
pratiques
elles sont toujours là chaque jour on
apprend qu'il ya un nouveau scandale est
ce que pour vous les états sont démunis
face
ça en partie probablement et il n'y a
qu'une action internationale commune
entre les différents grands pays
occidentaux qui peuvent régler ce type
de questions on vient de voir dans le
reportage
il ya un changement radical de la suisse
sous pression internationale et il est
probable qu'à partir de 2018
ce cas là sera réglé ça veut pas dire
que l'inventivité de la fraude fiscale
restant quand même un sport national et
international d'autres pays ne se
substitueront pas à la suisse pour des
pratiques similaires
on peut aussi retourner la question à
votre sens pourquoi est-ce que autant de
français n'ont qu'un désir fraudé le
fisc français
mais peut-être aussi parce qu'il y a des
impôts type isf qui sont trop élevés en
france trop confiscatoire en france et
que tout le monde cherche à détourner la
fisc français
j'aimerais qu'un jour quelqu'un nous
fasse un calcul prêt à le faire combien
coûte à la france
l'ensemble de ces évadés fiscaux qui
sont en suisse ou ailleurs
combien rapporte isf je crains
malheureusement que la fraude fiscale
dont on parle nous coûte beaucoup plus
cher que ce que rapporte isf est donc
peut-être qu'un jour il faudra arrêter
d'avoir en france des taxation
confiscatoire
quand on a un présent à un public qui
nous disait et qui a fait voter une taxe
à 75% pour ce qu'il ya de plus d'un
million d'euros
mais effectivement j'imagine que
malheureusement et je dis bien
malheureusement cela donc une envie
planquer leur fric d'ailleurs sur cette
question de l'évasion fiscale le sénat a
réitéré sa demande de création d'une
délégation
est-ce que selon vous le parlement doit
être plus en pointe sur ce sujet je
pense qu'il faut qu'on aille beaucoup
mieux le parlement sur le contrôle et
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
ont évalué qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
il y aura une proposition à faire par
exemple nous avons dans tous les
ministères
les inspections des corps d'inspection
nous avons dans tous les ministères des
évaluateurs les directions de
l'évaluation
je considère que pour renforcer le rôle
du parlement assemblée nationale comme
senna il faudrait transférer ces
différents corps d'inspection et c'est
direction de l'évaluation au parlement
pour qu'il soit beaucoup plus armé pour
contrôler l'action gouvernementale et
pour évaluer cette action
gouvernementale donc pourquoi pas sur
cette question là il ya une multitude
d'autres questions qu'on pourrait se
poser pour quelque part se dire quoi il
n'est pas normal de mon point de vue que
celui qui fait la loi que ce pli qui
applique la loi soit en même temps celui
qui dit c'était bien ou pas bien dire en
gros je fais quelque chose et je mets
value moi-même pour dire s'ils étaient
bien fait ou pas ses limites et donc
transférons le contrôle et l'évaluation
au parlement merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine daniel
hammer merci qui merci vont à paris
d'avoir fait d'avoir offert la semaine
parlementaire avec nous merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis et très bonne journée
sur la chaîne parlementaire